bro do you have a nutrition today i'm
gonna go over all the basics that you
need to know when it comes to nutrition
calories macronutrients micronutrients
weight loss weight gain your questions
answered let's go in order for you to
properly grasp nutrition 101 i want to
introduce you to a very good friend of
mine welcome to the dr mike channel dr
mike's nutrition triangle 101 education
basic
thingamabobbits uh i don't know what the
deal is with with all that basically i
have this triangle set up for you guys
so you can understand the three legs
that are super super important when
you're talking about eating healthy
calories now you've probably heard of
calories to some extent in the past the
technical definition of a calorie is the
amount of energy needed to raise one
kilogram of water by one degree celsius
and let's just stick with the idea that
calories are a form of energy and it's
found in food and your body needs it to
function optimally continuing on down
the nutrition triangle we have
macronutrients you may have heard of
them referred to as macros first up we
have proteins like fish next up fats
like olive oil and your favorite carbs
which can be cookies bread cakes all
that delicious stuff
oh um and i guess technically we have
alcohols too and that's the fourth
macronutrient but we're not going to
confuse this video any further this is a
really good time to let you know that i
partnered with the app life sum for this
video it allows you to track calories
macronutrients your weight set goals for
yourself set up delicious recipes
throughout this video i'm going to be
showing you how i utilize it when i'm
creating a healthy nutrition triangle
plan and you should definitely think
about grabbing the app for yourself all
right jumping back into the
macronutrients starting off with protein
protein is an incredibly important
component of every cell of the body hair
nails are actually mostly made up of
protein protein is a vital macronutrient
that your body uses to build and repair
muscle bone skin and even blood jumping
over to fat i want to first tell you
that i think dietary fats have gotten a
bad rap dietary fats are essential to
give you energy and support cell growth
they also help protect your organs and
keep your body warm and finally fats
help you absorb some nutrients as well
as producing some vital hormones like
testosterone furthermore fats break down
into saturated and unsaturated fats but
that can get controversial and a little
complex so let's save that for the
nutrition 201 video as for carbs
i'm not necessarily a huge fan
carp
don't worry i'm gonna tell them the good
parts about you too carbs break down
into three categories fibers starches
and sugars fiber is an incredibly
important component of carbohydrates
not only does it help your gut bacteria
survive and thrive but it could also
possibly curb your appetite lower your
cholesterol levels decrease some risks
of cancer that's pretty exciting and
that's the part of carbs i really do
enjoy starches are the most consumed
carbs on this planet you most often find
them in grains and root vegetables and
then we come to sugars you know what a
sugar is i know what a sugar is sugar
gets rapidly absorbed into our
bloodstream causing a huge blood sugar
spike therefore an insulin spike and
that can cause a lot of problems when
you overeat it and because it tastes so
good it's very easy to overeat
we went macro time to go micro the third
and final leg of our triangle is
micronutrients here we're talking about
vitamins and minerals vitamins
classically you hear vitamin b c d
minerals like zinc and iron these are
essential nutrients for our life the
reason why they're called essential is
because for the most part our body is
unable to make these on its own and we
need to get them from our diets if
you're low on vitamins that can hurt
your energy levels your immune system
your ability to clot and so much more
and if you're low on minerals your bones
won't form properly you won't grow
properly you could possibly be anemic
this is why these bad boys are so
essential yeah yeah something you have
to know is that all diets are not not
created equal and i'm gonna run through
a single example with you right now so
that you can follow along let's say
there are two people in a given
situation they have the same maintenance
calories and they're looking to lose
weight person a decides to follow the
cookie diet and they're gonna aim to eat
1500 calories of cookies a day which is
500 calories below their required
maintenance person b is also going to be
eating 1500 calories a day but they're
gonna be following the mediterranean
diet basically a whole foods plant-based
diet who do you think i'm gonna say is
following the healthy diet i mean it's
obvious but do you know why it's obvious
both people will actually lose weight so
you may say to yourself well so if
they're both losing weight why is one
worse than the other go back to my
little triangle that i created both are
eating a caloric deficit check but
person a is eating cookies which is
mostly sugars and some fats so they're
not getting a great balance of
macronutrients person b mediterranean
diet great balance of macronutrients
let's talk about micronutrients probably
the more important point of the
conversation here if you're following
the cookie diet what micronutrients are
in cookies mediterranean diet rich in
vitamins rich in minerals yes we want
you to lose weight if you're overweight
and yes we want you to consume less
calories but that's not where the story
ends we need to consider that whole
triangle of calories macros and
micronutrients
in the united states obesity has become
an epidemic so i understand why most
people want to lose weight it's actually
been proven in the best quality studies
keeping your weight healthy is one of
the most important things you can do to
maintain your health to live a long life
so if you're trying to lose weight or if
you're possibly underweight and want to
gain weight here's what i recommend you
do calculate your maintenance calories
you can do that through a calculator
online and then if you want to gain
weight add to the maintenance calories
and eat that if you want to lose weight
eat a little bit less than your
maintenance and you're going to be
losing weight what i recommend to my
patients is that ideally they lose or
gain a pound a week max because when you
start going into extremes that could
really mess with your body unless of
course you have a medical condition or
working with a nutritionist or doctor to
make life even easier for you i
recommend you just download life some
and plug in all your information and
it'll tell you what your maintenance
calories are or what you have to be
eating in order to gain or lose weight
it's such a simpler process when dieting
let's use myself as an example because
i'm actively dieting i'm trying to lose
some weight not a lot but i'm losing
weight trying to keep my muscle i'll
show you how i use lifesum to make that
happen all right let's start with
finding your plan i want to have a high
protein plan where i'll lose some weight
without going hungry and losing my
muscle so i hit high protein i hit start
plan it allows me to choose how much
protein i want to take in based on how
much exercise i'm doing let's keep it in
the midline here and do 0.9 grams of
protein per body weight some people say
to do 0.8 some people say to do one
let's keep it simple and do it right in
the middle hit continue it says i should
be focusing on eating foods that are
rich in protein i agree it gives me my
breakdown in calories and macronutrients
it gives you some basic do's and don'ts
which is awesome you hit start plan boom
it tells me how many calories i have to
eat today how many i've eaten how many
i've burned how many carbs i have to eat
how many proteins i have to eat how many
fats i have to eat so let's add what i
had for breakfast i ordered out actually
because i was busy don't judge me but
we got muscle
maker
grill i had a wrap it's called a rocky
balboa wrap boom right there we're gonna
add it to the diary and you can see
right here you click breakfast and it
says we had 59 grams of protein with a
little happy face because that's what we
need to do it shows you how many
calories i had i should have aimed for
about 700 calories i did 646 which is
close enough because throughout the day
it'll average out and then if you look
back onto the main diary here now i have
1500 calories left for the day it shows
you my breakdown of my macronutrients
you don't have to track the calories you
don't have to put anything down on paper
that can get very complicated and
intimidating you now have a solid
foundation in understanding nutrition
and what healthy eating truly means when
you're thinking about nutrition always
remember that little triangle of
calories macronutrients and
micronutrients so you can decide what's
healthy and what's not trust me there's
a lot of nuance when it comes to
nutrition and i didn't want to bog this
video down with controversy in general
the field of nutrition research is an
absolute mess and we'll save that for
the future videos for now i just wanted
you to have a solid understanding for
you to have a healthy and happy
conversation with your nutritionist
doctor trainer you got the basics so
click here for my diet reviews to truly
become a master and huge thank you to
life some for making this video happen
stay happy and healthy
you